what is up animation I'm your host Kyra
keemstar and let mean what is that sound
man it's her neighbor what neighbor
they're your neighbors so he keeps
playing this music all day yeah bro I
can't work like this man i'm gonna go
over there I now come with me let's go
over there and tell them to stop playing
that music I can't record like this time
the camera bring the camera because I
want the cops to see how loud he's
playing it if he doesn't stop I'm
bringing the cops all
morning this is on a one recording ready
someone open
blow
what
it was tough
totoro yeah girl our new neighbors
Potter Oh me Chris we're such big band
man we love you we love your movies bro
what no no never mind don't worry about
it don't worry about it like rear new
neighbors like so nice to meet you I'm
Hannah Magnus's goes and like pute fans
we're huge fan sir okay i will just
leave it's cool yeah hey great to meet
you guys yeah to you believe that our
new new bird is total that's crazy man
what do you think isn't that crazy I
think it's crazy and they have total
likes to party I saw like five chicks in
there I don't know if you guys noticed
damn hey guys so I hope you like this
little short skit we did with our new
neighbor and new best friend totoro he
looks a little bit bigger on screen and
the movies but you know what is just
because the camera makes you look taller
just look at Tom Cruise this was just a
short skit did stay tuned for more
longer skits coming up very soon we've
been busy with some school and work
stuff lately but we're gonna get back
into it hope you guys enjoy this hope
you stay tuned and see you later space
cowboys